okay I'm off to a new five minute game
let's see I'm got a women international
master saponin from india i think so
always got to be am cautious almost
Indian boys and girls are not bad she's
a young player I don't know yeah we got
them gone pre-attack a weekly remember
that this would pull really a long time
since I looked at this don't I win a
piece was safar sir some brilliant trick
hmm maybe not be five at some point
I don't know if there's a great trick
I'll see you soon enough I think okay
catch it with the night now what may
take on b5 but if I capture with the
king then I g5 or something hmm I don't
know she's playing this all instantly no
idea this some sort of great trap to be
honest I don't get it I just have an
extra piece okay for 42 points but still
okay yeah 96 might be a problem and are
still not g5 yeah my king doesn't have a
really great place here I'm thinking
about rook f8 may be covering f7 and
somewhat preventing lagi 5 i'm not sure
when marking should go maybe it needs to
stay there for the time being I need to
block the check
still maybe 95 and his six is hang
not sure what I play in this case King
c8 maybe a 96 check yeah let's let's
still somewhat uncomfortable
you cannot really cover a seven decently
nite nite CH looks very passive
pool
ok let's go a g5 for the moment and try
to I'm not sure maybe she should we take
with a night then I get at least get rid
of this night I'll get rid of some peace
at least if she takes on a seven I need
to trade off some pieces here if
possible of course there's a check on b6
but I thought I could just go to see
eight then on the check on d6 I have
King be eight it looks very shaky not
sure what this move is doing actually
maybe if I have an ID for to get rid of
some pieces
yeah I'm down to one minute 18 very
strange game I'm pretty sure that wasn't
enough compensation for the piece but
the term was really uncomfortable to
play this way I should get it read that
list of some some pieces maybe ease the
pressure somewhat I don't like to but
let's simplify here time were me
oops I'll take this this was nice
check got two extra pieces known really
should be enough
I need to be cautious the bishop and
night mate would be really young tricky
with this time okay
check check check yeah the airport
should decide check check check me who
this was a difficult one summer white
got really really someone unpleasant
compensation not sure if I but I really
counted users as well as the proper
sacrifice but what should I play here
I'm sure maybe it wasn't that bad what I
actually played but wasn't wasn't easy
to blame this was suddenly good for
white at some point okay let's start the
next one